bonjour kiev se prépare à la défense
vous voyez qu'il ya des troupes russes
qui essaie dans ce recul et kiev mais
quand vous avez vu les russes n'ont
aucun succès à saisir d'autres villes
ukrainien s'offrir centre essonne au sud
très proche de l'ectrims et ses deux
seules villes qui sont qu'ils ont réussi
à prendre
mais malheureusement pour la population
les citoyens de personnes n'acceptent
pas cette occupation alors qu'hier se
tient et se prépare à la défense il ya
beaucoup de gens qui s'inscrit dans la
défense territoriale
la vraie question est dans lequel
barbarie poutine va être prêt pour
attaquer kiev disons est ce qu'il est
prêt de bombardements massifs et
d'attaqués de missiles etc c'est pour ça
que les ukrainiens disant coréen parfois
été nous affirmer le ciel à
avoir une plus davantage dans le ciel
contre les missiles russes contrôlées
les forces aériennes parce que c'est ça
que les rues sont les plus barbares dans
la terre dans la l'opération de
terrienne ils sont en fait ils ont
beaucoup de pertes et les ukrainiens
sont très efficaces en attendant cet
assaut qui semble se préparer il se pose
vous le dit myriam aux locaux la
question de la satisfaction des besoins
de base en temps de guerre manger boire
se chauffer comment cela se présente y
est vous
les magasins sont presque vides donc
c'est très difficile d'acheter quelque
chose alors si tu as des rosaires c'est
bien
les pharmacies le plus je pense que une
des choses les plus pros problématique
c'est des pharmacies par exemple on
essaie de avec des volontaires d'aidé
aux gens qui ont besoin de des médecins
et en fait ça peut être très
problématique surtout pour les gens qui
souffrent des dix ont des maladies
chroniques des maladies du coeur
c'est très difficile de hier par exemple
j'ai cherché un jeu chez des médicaments
et g j'ai été dans 10 pharmacies je
faisais la queue pour acheter des
médicaments des
environs qui a besoin d'eux alors ça
peut être difficile mais beaucoup des
choses sont fermés beaucoup de magasins
presque tous les magasins sont fermés
mais quand je vous ai dit que
malgré cette station il ya
cet esprit décisif et en fait quand je
parle avec des gens qui restent kiev et
sont en fait très très décisif et il
trouve pas que les russes peuvent saisir
et sur l'art la résistance des
ukrainiens justement quelle est votre
analyse des réactions internationales
envers la russie est ce que vous les
trouvez suffisante à la hauteur
ils étaient suffisantes pour 2014 alors
2014 la russie a commencé la guerre
contre l'ukraine a occupé les crimes et
a occupé une partie d'une base si on
avait les sanctions comme ça sur le
suivre sur aube burbank vraiment de
s'actionne très très fort un contre des
russes à 2014 on n'aura pas cette
situation parce que finalement la russie
faisant face section 2014 c'est là elle
a réussi à regrouper son économie
malheureusement le source le sources de
revenus le plus important c'est du gaz
et le pétrole n'a pas été coupée alors
maintenant on paye tous les ukrainiens
départ leur vie et on paye tous pour
cette myopie de la communauté
internationale
autrement bien sûr on apprécie beaucoup
les de la communauté internationale sait
très bien que il ya sept cette pression
économique parce que en fait mon analyse
secure la russie c'est une empire
blessés qui essaient de qui a perdu les
territoires qui la considèrent qu'on les
normes comme les siens essaye de
récupérer si tu essaies territoire mais
l'histoire nous montre que ça ne réussit
jamais donc ce la prochaine question
volodymyr beaulaincourt vous êtes
philosophe est ce que vous diriez que le
cren est confronté face à la russie
aujourd'hui à un défi existentiel
mais je termine mon propos précédents
donc l'histoire nous montre que l'
empire blessés ne peut jamais regagné
ses territoires et finalement quand elle
essaie de le faire ça tombe à pour
l'ukraine bien sûr bien sûr c'est une
bataille et existentielle parce que ce
que poutine ap les nazis ukrainien en
fait il fait la guerre contre l'ukraine
lui mer et contrôler d'ukraine elle-même
donc il veut détruire l'ukraine comme
nation comme peuple comme la langue
comme identité et en fait c'était
plusieurs phare dans l'histoire au 20e
siècle par exemple donc c'est une
répétition ce qui était fait mais l
ukraine quand vous voyez très décisifs
et très fort dans une résistance vous
dites aussi que ces opérations
militaires de vladimir poutine le seul
ne sont pas seulement une menace pour
l'ukraine mais sont orientés vers toute
l'europe tout le monde civilisé
démocratique expliquez-nous
c'est évident c'est ce que put une ce
coaching dire clairement qui fait la
guerre contre le temps et contre
l'europe et pas contre le crains si vous
suivez la propagande russe depuis des
années maintenant depuis dix ans
peut-être ils disent tout le temps que
hatton bas s'ils font la guerre contre
l'otan contre l'europe contre les états
unis par contre l'ukraine ils disent des
bêtises comme quoi il ya des forces de
l'otan qui qui font la guerre à double
face aujourd'hui cette nuit on a eu une
missile frappes de missiles sur nos
veille à brive qui est 20 kilomètres de
la frontière polonaise band kilomètres
de la frontière de l'atteindre une
européenne alors
c'est évident pour nous que si l'ukraine
tombe la russie va attaquer l'otan merci
beaucoup vous le dire il ya monaco